the California and san Francisco departments of Public Health and the
CDC have confirmed that a recent case of covid
19 among an individual in California was caused by the
omicron variant.
The Ami green variant has been detected in the U.
S.
Health officials say the patient recently returned from South africa where scientists first identified the
variant in november.
Covid cases in the U.
S.
Were already increasing since late october and we're averaging more than 90,000 day before
thanksgiving when millions of people traveled to gather with family and friends.
Hospitalizations have been creeping upwards as well.
Even before the variant was confirmed in the US the CDC strengthened its booster
recommendation saying that everybody 18 and older should get a booster shot.
We've also seen some tighter travel restrictions and mask advisories in places like New York.
There's still a lot about the variant that we don't know with the small number of cases.
It is very difficult to know whether or not this particular variant is going to
result in severe disease.
Researchers are concerned about the various because of its high numbers of mutations,
some of which have already been linked to higher transmissibility or a partial evasion of the immune
response from vaccination or prior infection with other variants.
President Biden said monday that his administration was working with Pfizer Moderna and johnson and
johnson on plans for vaccines or boosters in case they're needed to combat the variant but
Mr biden said that as of now officials don't think such measures will be needed.
I will also direct the FDA and the CDC to use the fastest process available
without cutting any corners for safety to get such vaccines
approved and on the market if needed.
Health officials in infectious disease experts were already anticipating an increased number of covid
cases and hospitalizations this winter as colder weather ushers,
people in many parts of the country indoors and people gathered together for the holidays.
Public health officials say that the things that we've been doing all along to help protect ourselves against other
variants,
including Delta,
which is most of the cases in the country right now can also help against a micron.
CBC continues to recommend wearing a mask in public indoor studies in these
areas,
washing your hands frequently and physical distancing.
We don't know a lot about this variant right now,
but researchers across the world are working on it and we should have more answers in the next couple of
weeks.
Yeah.